j'en viens maintenant à cette
information que je vous annoncer hier
l'inculpation qui sera effective demain
de maurice pas pour l'ancien ministre du
budget inculpation à sa demande pour
avoir accès au dossier d'accusation
l'accusation très sévère qui lui sont
adressées 2000 annonce le 5 mai 81 le
canard enchaîné accuse monsieur maurice
papon d'avoir joué un rôle dans la
politique antijuive de vichy l'occupant
à l'appui ce journal affirme que le
ministre du budget du gouvernement barre
qui fut pendant l'occupation secrétaire
général de la préfecture de la gironde a
contribué c'est toujours le canard
enchaîné qui l'écrit à la déportation
vers drancy de plus de 1600 juifs
bordelais l' affaire papon éclate
projetant ses accusations maurice papon
demande la constitution d'un jury
d'honneur composé de résistants le 15
décembre 81 le jury d'honneur constituée
à la demande de maurice papon rend sa
sentence le jury d'honneur d'un acte à
monsieur maurice papon de ce qu'il fut
bien affiliés aux forces françaises
combattantes à compter du 1er janvier
1943 est attributaire de la carte de
combattant volontaire de la résistance
le jury conclut veut néanmoins au nom
même des principes qu'ils croyaient
défendre et faute d'avoir été mandaté
par une autorité qualifiée de la
résistance française pour demeurer à son
poste
monsieur pape aurait dû démissionner de
ses fonctions au mois de juillet 1942 à
bordeaux les conclusions du jury
d'honneur sont rapidement contesté
depuis plus de vingt ans michel
slitinsky résistants bordelais accumule
les archives de la période de
l'occupation et il a trouvé beaucoup de
choses 164g parcours eu de nombreuses
villes en allemagne de nombreuses villes
en france et en définitive chacun ne pas
cumuler des centaines de documents
ces documents sont accablants payé le 22
mars 1943
monsieur pape ont écrit à l'attention
plein temps dans polisse
l'honneur de vous prier de bien vouloir
procéder à l'arrestation immédiate des
juifs ci après désignées et 6 nuls
secrétaire général maurice papon
un autre document accablant le 24 août
nous faisons un rapide retour en arrière
nous apercevons que monsieur pape en
consigne sur une note manuscrite une
instruction qui l'arrangent une paris
d'après monsieur le guen adjoint de
bousquet chef de la police des affaires
juives
il y a lieu d'exécuter les ordres cesse
c'est un hôte encore signé par maurice
papon geslin et un autre du 16 mars 53
qui a pour objet le transfert des juifs
du camp de mérignac à drancy
c'est en allemand et en français
monsieur pape ont écrit au chef de la
police allemande à bordeaux je cite je
vous serai obligé de vouloir bien
demandé aux services les transports de
la feldkommandantur le convoiement par
train express aux rapides afin de
remédier aux inconvénients signalés
notamment en matière de surveillance des
internés peut-on être plus clair mais je
voudrais quand même faire une remarque
monsieur pat on prétend être résistant
de plus 1er janvier 1943
si nous faisons un calcul nous
apercevons que dans ses services vichy à
temps complet il a permis dans
l'importation de vie sont nos déporté
dans sa deuxième étape de résistance
il a quand même facilité la déportation
de 779 juif est une fusion direz vous
c'est je crois la famille des résistants
qui doit en conclure
est ce que vraiment un résistant
pouvait-il arrêter les juifs
à l'issue de cette enquête nous avons
demandé à monsieur maurice papon de
répondre à ces accusations
il s'est toujours refusé à toute
déclaration il n'a d'ailleurs accordé
aucune interview
jusqu'à sa demande d'inculpation